hi everyone and welcome back to Castle
hores I'm serene my name's Jess McDonald
is a my name sorry just like to change
some stuff up it's a stream you guys are
always say we're way too bright so we're
playing more in the dark and hell i also
changed couple of things with the way
that you'll see the game come up when we
swap over so let me know what you think
of everything today I've chosen a game
that I really wanted to play on stream
and that is dead light eh I guess it's
kind of like a zombie survival horror
platforming yeah it's a very different
take on the whole zombie apocalypse
genre this game came out in 2012 um it
was originally released on xbox live
arcade and then releasing pc later on
everyone is saying this is not a hard
game we're trying to think different I
don't want to see anything it's not
straight up horror then you guys can
vote on that and let us know that's very
pretty this is very cool do you think I
can make that jump uh yes I believe in
you
they'll just go down yeah yeah Eric if
you jump over they'll just go down I can
hang off edges okay ah ha ha ha so dumb
for oh good oh no oh I'd I fell to your
death I hit jumper he did a giant again
long distance jump whoops I was a
definitely not a long usage it jump oh I
like how it reacts to this is cooling
you let your wax red mama baby all right
huh oh no no no he's janitor why doesn't
he flirt no oh no haha oh dear they're
pretty fun why are they costed another
foster than me know the zombies are so
in lumbering in the bastard please do
not be a good why madam oh look at that
layin sides Luke late title card oh snap
shot I like he's marrying this is he's
like a run here long this is a way this
is it oh oh oh my god what do I did
climb flips comes along I'm time I was
gonna bathe it so I have an inventory no
I just haven't got a diary oh my god why
what you yeah all these random lockers
so much age of my diary has a ring
capable he's a stash of diary into other
people [ __ ] he gets a kick out of it
kick kick King movies oh my god good job
Oh title of wider zombies keep walking
on day like this nothing he looks dull
you don't set off car loans
Hodgins right oh my god Oh keep running
it's the control scheme it's very funny
I think just keep running I don't think
like oh you can hug it possible right
cuz it's two-dimensional this world I'm
gonna 10 through dimensional so i hope i
have when there's only apocalypse comes
that it will be in three dimensions
melee attacks on really polish because
he gets tired too quickly right i can't
just take on hordes and hordes of
zombies yeah well i guess that would be
like real life yes grow back you said
like in real life you can't fight a
horde of zombies by yourself so true hey
zombies delicious human meat for you ego
as it would start pakala this isn't
happening cool huh
yep don't know what the point of that
was laughs I'm over it no funny oh
they're right in I'll could open that
door that I could get through now I can
get to an easier without having to crash
hey better on your knees okz haha I'm
sorry go back to sleep oh that was close
uh yeah do it just just just come on
faith jump honey you can do it why when
you rub a sh you mean the stuff oh oh
yeah no hummus this is bad I'm sorry ker
oh come on what my dog a little
apprentice behind a stir make sure you
always ain't for the head Randy always
in the head look I hate that number
that's my least favorite thing that
anyone doesn't dialogue is like
repeating them like slower it's like
i'll see you again later see you again
later [ __ ] love shooting padlocks
it's the biggest [ __ ] you too padlocks a
crow it's probably the same bulletproof
crow from before kind of pull on me as
that trying yeah you're bad you're
probably alienated all the crows of this
game because of that scene hahaha you
like the chickens and Zelda sand bagging
you get an achievement for every second
thing you do in this game I'll kill you
freaks now that's racist they cover like
Angie right oh yeah oh you're the king
bounce up whoa elated oh good what I
should damage from that yeah I know but
that was like really impressive run roll
all look at you god damn it woman so
impressed me haha
I'm gonna die now I hope you like a
friend Cassie Carlos dead and now you
are too oh my god did you just say that
yeah yeah and I said I'm a query okay um
can this door go any slower you know
it's not like I have any way ya reckon
it's not like I have any minute BAC
crotch crashy crowds crash crowd no
working now you can do it you can get
three now run he's talking to himself
don't you actually yep ah the old man's
problem haha do you keep running parkour
style didn't attend parkour crouch style
but you're only my back off just a bit
of nation so decided we've been bitten
she lies time haha actually haha second
time I've go back I'll let you go first
hi guys best and we'll jump oh ok yeah
kick Lyman good gay club oh one of those
time I didn't know how eager i look like
in my guy Oh
aah oh no aah we always made it oh oh my
god Oh what yeah but now oh my god new
zombies hate on us random zombie jesus
take very good let's say that's how we
were supposed to do it slingshot
interesting I wouldn't really go for
that during the zombie apocalypse but
each to their own all those spikes that
the rat put up all the hard work yeah
gonna have to set this all up again for
the next guy oh oh oh my god oh [ __ ] out
bulls oh my god you made it oh god I
can't see these railings and this is why
I tend my mic down Oh Shh didn't see
that there may indeed want a role to
avoid damage I rolled that time he
started going to the role animation so I
just roll through the spine over them
now I think yeah oh look that's they
felt sorry for me oh wow ok Scoob and
don't think you could roll through
receive sharp spikes as we can get up
there
oh haha nope that worked oh that one
yeah oh hello come alive my house to
ours it's just like these victories blow
my spectacular to me how are you gonna
hit that one science damn it doesn't
grow three time why are you like peggle
haha should be oh I'd to crouch yeah
something gonna leap out of the water
oops I he can't swim no he doesn't feel
um bees he feeds the water fire my son
before these men dude you're just like
crazy dude totally yeah Oh grace nice
room you just took the Polaroid of his
son you just stole that why do I may
take you that just in case you never
know when you want to get great when you
need to climb an extra food nehal hyah
wah damn it I hate it we hold about that
I time or from falling than i do just
movies all that for another probably
another picture of a relative he'll ever
see again you can steal I love how he
locks like a yes like different brush
companion crate it looks easy to
replicate to I could make that venue
free enough i was talking it's like tell
you whatever your son Roland dark oh no
it's me how we gonna get this pickle
sweet jump that was dead light these
five ahora platform game came out in
2012 you can buy that on steam if you're
also interested or xbox live arcade
mm-hmm Jess what are we doing next week
we're playin lucious yeah if you are
wish in hives real we did run
drop all throughout a stream the one you
just watched and it was between leashes
sequestered fires paranormal and pulse
Lucius is one which is three more votes
on the curse of Horus so don't worry the
Crytek engine because the virus will
definitely be in the next poll that we
do but um yes we're going to start up a
thing when you guys can get more
involved in the games that you want to
say so next one day we'll be finishing
Lucius it'll be the very end so if you
didn't like it it'll be over soon anyway
but if you do want to join us for the
very end of that stream will be back
same time next week awesome thanks very
much for joining thanks dad bye